Всіх вітаю є сьогодні Хороші Новини зі
страсбурга де знаходиться Європейський
суд з прав людини от про це будемо
говорити е сьогодні і не забувайте
підписуватися коментувати лайкати у нас
точно має бути більше в українському
сегменті в інтернеті в YouTube каналі
телеграмі ну на всіх платформах а отже
український генерал Ігор Павловський
виграв справу свою він звертався з
заявою до Європейського Суду з прав
людини зі скаргою щодо неправомірного
свого затримання і тримання під вартою в
СІЗО
лук'янівці за що затримали Ігора
павловського за те що він посмів
поставити на наше військово-морські сили
на обладнання їх
поставити військові катери виготовлені в
Україні і були затримані і пан
Павловський і директор заводу кузня
нарибальський так само за те що от не
такі катери там не такі детали і таке
інше А виготовляли ці катери військові в
період з 15го по 19-й роки коли жодна
країна в світі нам не те що катерів чи
там кораблів не поставляла а навіть на
деталі на комплектуючі було повне
ембарго і ви всі це пам'ятаєте Ну так
само і те що український флот було
знищена вкрадена по суті Росією в
Чорному морі в Криму власне для нас було
критично
необхідно створити виготовити кілька
хоча би кораблів катерів які несли потім
в ахту і в Маріуполі І до речі один з
таких катерів брав зараз
е участь і був задіяний і під час
звільнення острова зміїний але от Ігоря
павловського кілька місяців тримали
принижували в СІЗО і зараз він виграв
цей суд Який визнав Європейський суд
зправ людини що це був було неправомірне
абсолютно бездоказове затримання
Утримання під вартою е не було жодних
підстав якщо там є кримінальна справа
якісь питання тримати Генерала бойового
який з 14-го року до речі під Маріуполем
захищав Україну тримати його під вартою
Україна тепер має сплатити компенсацію
Ігорю два
2600 євро і от мабуть було би правильно
щоб ці кошти сплачувала не держава
України не українці а Банкова яка цю
справу породила і судді які от були
причетні до цього тримання під вартою
Ігоря я нагадаю що тоді
всі люди які там приходили на ці
судилища зібрали кошти разом з фондом
Порошенка внесли заставу для того щоби
пану Ігорю змінили запобіжний захід Так
само як і директору заводу
кузняно-рибальській і до речі ну ще раз
наголошую що це чи не єдині були катери
від військові які залишалися на
озброєнні військово-морського флоту
України і вони і зараз ці катери задіяні
в певних операціях
і виконують свої бойові завдання Під час
цієї страшної війни власне так само не
закрита справа не тільки досі проти
Ігоря хоча в Європейському суді визнали
що це затримання було абсолютно
неправомірне така сама політична справа
була відкрита Як ви пам'ятаєте кілька
років тому проти бойового Генерала
Дмитра марченка героя насправді України
справжнього легендарного марчели який
врятував і Миколаїв і Одесу від
захоплення зараз російськими окупантами
під час уже повномасштабного вторнення
Ну немає людини мабуть в Україні Хто би
не знав Дмитра марченка не любив його не
шанував І от минулого ти тижня парламент
проголосував навіть звернення до
президента Зеленського нагородити Дмитра
марченка від знакою герой України він
абсолютний герой але справа оця
політизована ганебна справа проти Дмитра
марченка Генерала і досі не закрита Хоча
вона розвалюється хоча Воно видно вже що
вона Ну нікудишня нікчемна за що
заарештували свого часу Дмитра марченка
за начебто неякісні бронежилети за
сттували ці бронежилети 16 000 і вони
згнили на складах А коли розпочалося
повномасштабне вторнення Україна От і
наше військо виявилося що не вистачає
катастрофічно броніків ви пам'ятаєте що
тягли їх тоді волонтери з усіх країн де
тільки було Можливо тому що така от Ну
якась диверсія була так само і досі не
закриті кримінальні справи проти Тетяни
чорноволтання зараз на херсонському
напрямку от останні вже півтора року як
знаєте вона брала участь у звільненні
Київщини Таня чи не єдина жінка яка є
командиром роти
е бійців які працюють зі стугнею Вони
працюють е по знищенню ворожої техніки і
тільки у Тані на її рахунку кілька і
бронемашин ворожих і танків які були
підбиті і на Київщині і на Херсонщині і
Тані не має державних нагород хоч вона
ще раз наголошую чи не єдина в Україні
жінка яка керує взводом і конкретно вона
знищила е ну Вже десяток одиниць мабуть
ворожжої техніки але про титаній дозі
триває кримінальна справа за що її
звинувачує
ее система за те що начебто Таня
причетна для до
підпалу офісу Партії Регіонів під час
Революції гідності От коли там на
Липський АА загинули в цьому в цій
пожежі люди хоча ми пам'ятаємо які
страшні події
відбувалися в січні в лютому і на
майдані і поблизу маріїнського парку і
скільки там було тітушок який там
взагалі був безлад і скільки було
вбито Героїв Небесної Сотні І от дбр
доблесно відрепортувало кілька днів тому
що розкриті замовники цих масових
вбивств на Майдані які по суті стали
притечею страшної агресії Російської
Федерації страшної війни і що за цим
стояв Янукович і його банда оці всі
міністри які мали російські паспорти от
але всі вони втікли в Росію а Таню
чорноголи досі от не закрита кримінальна
справа її судять за за начебто підпал
офісу Партії Регіонів так само не
закрита і досі кримінальна справа проти
Олександра погребиського він теж воює
він був поранений поблизу селидару і
його з звинувачують в тому що начебто
він облив зеленкої поблизу парламенту
державного зрадника депутата від опзж а
пана Волошина сам цей Олег Волошин давно
втік його теж звинувачують в державній
зраді Волошина немає погребиський воює
справа проти погребиського є хоча навіть
на відео яке тоді там вдалося да бачити
всім видно що Олександр підходить уже до
облито зеленкою Волошина і навпаки
допомагає йому там витерти обличчя і
таке інше До речі коли на Порошенка
якийсь тітушка напав з зеленкою те що
облив під час там якихось акцій протесту
А мені здається це був 2021 рік чи це Чи
це був День незалежності але Питання в
тому що ніякої кримінальної справи ніхто
не порушував тому що очевидно що за цим
теж стояли
А ну стояли ті самі хто хто влаштовував
судилища проти військових Ну і одна з
найганебніших справ яка і досі триває і
тут взагалі жахлива ситуація тому що
якщо принаймні Ігоря павловського Дмитра
марченка тримали під вартою кілька
місяців і потім дозволили змінити
запобіжний захід і внести за них
заставу то зараз триває таке судилище
над романом червинським це офіцер який
якраз був безпосередньо вів е справу по
затриманню
вагнерівців пам'ятаємо яких вони хотіли
вимати виманути з Білорусі наші
спецслужби і затримати цих серійних
вбивці і покадків ця справа На жаль була
зраджена і провалилася так от зараз
доганяють червинського його звинувачують
в тому що начебто він провів невдалу
операцію вже під час повномасштабного
вторгнення і через його дії було
обстріляно
литов ще в кропивницькому поблизу
Кропивницького ну Вибачте це війна під
час війни є вдалі операції є невдалі
операції і мабуть про дуже багато речей
ми дізнаємося після війни це нормально
але тільки ми бачимо один випадок коли
людину
офіцера на рахунку якого дуже багато
справжніх подвигів знищених ворогів
проведених унікальних рації зараз
тримають у клітці і не дають навіть
право на зміну запобіжного заходу на те
щоби там була застава
чи депутати європейської солідарності
були готові взяти його на поруки от не
дозволяю це зробити очевидно що і по
справі червинського є дуже великі шанси
виграти в Європейському суді з прав
людини Але знову буде держава Україна
відповідати за неправомірні дії тих хто
от оці справи придумує і тих суддів які
в це грають це дуже і дуже неприємно і
звичайно якщо ми будуємо правову державу
маємо дуже а протистояти таким речам
називати речі своїми іменами взагалі
мабуть треба вже вносити зміни до закону
яким би от самі Судді які приймають
неправомірні рішення потім сплачували ці
компенсації Можливо так буде більше
відповідальність і слідування букві і
духу закону а під час розгляду справ
взагалі ще є от кілька речей які не
вкладаються в голові Під час цієї війни
Ну наприклад от
зараз одна з
найбільших вітчизняних компаній яка
виробляє тепловізори дуже дефіцитні
сьогодні на них там справжній ажиотаж
війські війську і ця компанія arрchр
вона відома з 2014 року поскаржилося що
нагрянули Минулого тижня до них в офіс
набу
з обшуками і забрали і не тільки там
документацію якусь фінансову а
й
чертежі інформацію яка вже носить Ну
такий
характер виробництва і по суті це блокує
сьогодні в виробництво тепловізорів
очевидно що ну звучить дуже дика не менш
дика звучить уже третя сьогодні
заява виробниче об'єднання Луч - це
унікальне абсолютно державне
підприємство яке задіяно у виробництві
наших ракет от всі знають Нептун да яким
було там знищено крейсер цей
Москва але тут на цей Луч замість того
щоб допомагати йому працювати вже втрече
прийшла така державна аудиторська служба
яка просто
кошмарить Луч вимагаючи від нього там
теж документацію про те на яких умовах
це підприємство
поставляє І взагалі співпрацює з нашим
військово-промисловим комплексом з
міністерством оборони і поставляє там
свої розробки безумство здається от під
час війни Ми всі маємо навпаки нашого
виробника особливо якщо мова йде про
снаряди про ракети бо на це страшний
дефіцит у війську всіляко підтримувати а
не блокувати його діяльність але от
держаудитслужба просто продовжує
сьогодні знущатися над українським
виробником у сфері оборонки і там
взагалі трапилася дика історія значить
нова Ця керівниця її звати Алла белаєва
була призначена на посаду керівника цієї
державної аудиторської служби в грудні
Минулого року от вона вже напрацювалася
так що її внесли до списку миротворця за
те
що по суті створює
припони українським підприємствам
державним і приватним які працюють у
сфері впк але ще гірше вчинив уряд
значить уряд уряд прийняв дві
взаємовиключні постанови однією
постановою значить сказав що не може
бути під час війни будь-який прибуток
отримувати виробництва в сфері впк ну
погодьтесь це нонсенс тому що
виробництво воно ж бізнес робиться за
підприємництво заради прибутку можна
звичайно обмежити його маржу там це це
нормально особливо під час війни але
прийняли постанову якою сказали що
будь-який прибуток візкового виробництва
це є збиток для держави так хто тоді
буде працювати в Україні з державою
робити зброю поставляти зброю якщо тебе
потім прийдуть держаудитслужба беб там я
не знаю хто дбр там ще хтось і тебе
просто заарештують за те що ти працював
на оборонку потім другою постановою
прийняли дозвіл що можна такки
Отримувати прибуток Але існує одна і
друга постанова І зараз є купа
кримінальних справ в рамках яких от
кошмарі
виробника і не дають можливість
розвиватися і ще у вересні вже змушена
була в це втратитися Верховна Рада
України ми прийняли постанову звернення
таке до уряду до речі співавторства там
всіх фракцій і моно більшості
європейської солідарності бо ми ж тут
точно займаємо одну позицію яким
закликали уряд негайно припинити оці
перевірки під час війни Да безпідставні
якщо вони якщо є корупція є підставні
перевірки це одна історія А якщо ви
просто
блокуєте виробництво оборонне сьогодні
то це якась Є диверсія розібратися з цим
і дати можливість працювати І от
парламент приймає одне рішення уряд на
це ніяк не реагує і бачимо сьогодні
приходить в Луч чергова перевірка власне
ми зараз європейська Солідарність
готуємо запит до уряду з вимогою
звільнити цю пані з
держаудитслужби варто мабуть туди
ставити професійних людей які будуть
аудит проводити там де є корупція яйця
по 17 вони не помічають а от
виробництво наших ракети снарядів
блокують важко З оцим цим друзі Чесно
кажучи боротися але іншого у нас виходу
немає тому що маємо захищати честь
військових От і зверніть увагу теж
скільки нам розповідали коли тільки
європейська Солідарність ходила в суд
захищаючи там Дмитра марченка витягуючи
його з цього СІЗО да розповідали нам про
бронежилети а от Уявіть собі щоби не пан
генерал марченка в Миколаєві і в Одесі
на початку повномасштабного вторгнення
навіть Важко уявити там хід війни якби
міг
змінитися і очевидно що і генерал
Павловський і Роман червинський і Таня
Чорновол і Олександр погребивський і всі
ті хто можуть да докласти свої мізки
своє стратегічне бачення
свої вміння
військові захищати Україну Вони мають
бути в цьому задіяні не можна тут їм
заважати Це робити як от відбувається
зараз і тому друзі ми дуже раді сьогодні
Таким хорошим новинам зі страсбурга і
вітаємо Ігоря павловського його родину
всіх хто захищав Ігоря його адвокатів з
тим що це важливе рішення яке Сподіваюся
стане таким першим да важливим там
камінцем в те щоб взагалі закрити ці
надумані кримінальні справи проти
Генерала в Україні звичайно дуже важливо
щоби судді всі українські от прочитали
ці рішення І усвідомлювали що пора
припиняти політичне О
оце політичні справи проти військових
Звичайно безумство що і досі не закрита
справа проти А ще одна є справа ще не
закрита і досі справа проти Марусі
звіробій Уявіть собі Маруся воює вона
була важко поране під кліщівкою там було
вбито її коханого Він загинув військовий
герой А справа проти Марусі що вона там
чогось в емоціях сказала що не
сподобалася офісу президента і досі є
Мені
здається це
така навіть важко коментувати все це і
Софія Федина так само там справа досі
триває знаєте от у нас Минулого тижня
побили депутати від слуг громадянина про
з того там на вулиці з'ясувалось До речі
що це теж військового побили і ніяких
справ ніхто нікого не тягає а тут і досі
все це триває е носить це все як на мене
характер такого вибіркового
політичного переслідування це все дуже
негоже під час війни бо під час війни ми
маємо об'єднуватися навколо ключового Як
подолати ворога і і тут е ті наші
найкращі представники які своїми
подвигами своїм жертовністю своїм
професіоналізмом довели як вони вміють
воювати і захищати країну ми маємо їм
дякувати щодня а не проводити проти них
ці кримінальні справи тому Закликаємо
владу отак от подумати добре позакривати
Всі ці ганебні
абсолютно судилища і просто рухатися
подякувати подякувати всім людям які
воюють цей генерал Марченко це й Маруся
з робій це і Таня Чорновол це і Саша
погребиський випустити пана червінського
долучити
до зараз всіх операцій Ігоря
павловського бо з його досвідом точно
він тільки додасть сьогодні нашій
перемозі і отак от рухатися далі я так
думаю друзі переконана ви тут поділяєте
це моє бачення пишіть коментуйте